I always prefer to do something
than not to doing something.
So whenever,
even when wake up in the morning,
I want to go jogging or not
and I am tired,
I'm not going to jog today.
But I remember that
whenever I'm doing something
or when I do something,
I never regret.
Dotan Knaan, thank you for joining me
on 20 Minute Leaders.
How are you today?
Good, good.
Nice to meet you.
Happy to be here.
Thank you. We have a lot to cover.
But before we cover all the mileage
we have for this interview,
we have to talk about your bike journeys.
You started by mentioning to me
that you traveled with your wife
with 10 some of the bikes
all across Europe,
and you even traveled
with the whole family
on a non-competitive cycling event
through Iowa, right?
Yeah, yeah.
Bike is me. I am the bike.
So, also in the Silicon Valley
I used to bike every day
to work and back.
Here in Israel, now I'm in Israel, also,
we are in Tel Aviv
because in Tel Aviv,
you can cycle also everywhere.
So, I try to avoid my car.
And also it's good
because my son is very,
he's protesting against the
climate change.
So, I'm very proud to
that my son can be proud of me,
that I'm using bike, whenever I can.
And yeah, as a student,
I cycle with my wife for two months
in Europe with bike.
And again, then another trip
and that was in Scandinavia.
Then another time in Scotland.
And then in United States also,
I cycled of a lot.
And including with my family
one week we crossed Iowa
from one side to the other.
There is a big event
called, RAGBRAI,
and that was very, very good.
I'm constantly in awe.
The people that I'm speaking to,
like yourself, you're so busy
and you're so successful in your domain,
yet you have these incredible passions
and adventures
and you don't do them lightly.
You go all the way.
You traveled 2,000 miles
with your wife with ten.
So, you travel all across Iowa
with your family.
I'm gaining inspiration for myself.
But I have to go to the main event
and to the main mileage.
You're a researcher at Samsung.
You're an expert in computer vision
in augmented reality.
And I'm especially excited
for this episode
because I'm excited to talk about
what is augmented reality?
And where are we heading,
especially in the context of your work?
So, Dotan, maybe,
can you take me back a little bit
about your journey
into this computer vision space.
And then, tell me a little bit
about where we are?
Okay. So, personally,
my big one is more computer vision
and also a bit of computer graphics.
And for me, augmented reality,
or virtual reality, we can discuss it,
but that's why I like,
it is about the integration.
So, you take computer graphics
and computer vision
and integrate them
and have something that you see.
And for me also,
that's also something
that's for me is very important
is the feedback.
So, for me as a developer,
that's I develop something
and I get the feedback.
I don't need someone to tell me
if it's better or not.
I see if it's better.
I see the reality in front of me.
You are the user.
I'm the user.
It's not only better algorithm
that runs faster and someone say,
oh, now it's faster, more efficient.
What I like is just
the interaction with the computer,
with the screen.
And if it's augmented reality,
virtual reality is not only the screen,
it could be also glasses.
What drew you into computer vision
starting out?
Why going to computer vision?
What drew you into computer vision?
Yeah. So, to computer vision again,
that's because of visual aspect.
Because I see what I get
and understand the world
and how the computer
can understand the world,
and how computer can
can learn and it's got just,
I started 20 years ago,
even more 25 years ago
and it was not allowed so many cameras.
Now everything is cameras.
Every phone has a camera,
amazing camera.
So, the potential of computer vision
just grew and grew
and understanding
of the images much, much better.
And again the direction,
having been being able
to see what you're going,
that's what I like the most.
And what's also very interesting is,
though, because for us, the human,
it's you see something,
it's so obvious what you see.
But to teach a computer to understand
what you see, it's a big challenge.
And that's part of,
now, when we have augmented reality,
if you asked about augmented reality is,
you have two parts,
one is understanding the world
because you have to visualize.
So, maybe I'll just give a few words
about what is augmented reality
is also, there's virtual reality
where you see only
the virtual only the graphics.
You don't see the actual world.
You just see everything is graphics.
And there's augmented reality
or mixed reality.
There are some differences
between all that.
But in general,
let's call it augmented reality,
that's you have the world,
but on top of the world,
you have some object
that you add some information
to the world.
It could be,
through the screen of the phone like,
on the phone you see
the world with a camera
and also add some information.
So, Google has a lot of
the very good tool code
that gives you a lot of information,
you can use it and
it just gets better and better
because you understand the world.
You can understand plan,
you can understand
where everything is located.
Personally, I prefer as a developer
to work with the glasses.
In the glasses
like HoloLens Microsoft and those other
Magic Leap and other companies.
That's for me, that's the magic,
because then you really see the world
and then you also put again,
you put the graphics on top.
That extra layer.
Yeah, but extra layer.
But that's even more challenging because
you really have to understand the scene.
You really have to understand,
not only the scene
and where to put something,
but to also attract the head motion.
So, you have to understand
how the head moves.
Because then you can
really know how to render,
how to locate
the object in the right thing.
And if you don't do it right,
it looks wrong.
So, it's very, we as human again,
is very sensitive to that.
And it's very difficult to trick us.
And you know,
everything it also it has to work
very efficiently in real time
because you cannot have any latency.
That's another challenge
with augmented reality.
The speed should be very, very
processing speed should be
that's everything,
you have to be very efficient.
And every jittering,
in virtual reality you can cheat.
In augmented reality,
you cannot really cheat
because you see,
again, you can see the road.
And where it is now,
I think most of computer,
many, many companies,
big companies,
they try and do something.
And for many years now,
it's considered as something
that is the next things.
But it's still promising,
more promising than,
you have also Facebook and Google.
And I know some rumors about Apple.
But no one really makes money of that.
So, it's still potential because
when you have,
and they call it sometimes,
they call it like a Superman.
Once you have this abilities,
even if you don't like it,
that's the claim that in the future,
even if someone doesn't like it,
for example, I see you
and I get some information
that you cannot know about me,
I have some advantage on top of you.
I don't really like the approach
but in general, that's reality.
So, if I have something
that with augmented reality,
going to get more information
than someone without it.
And so, one day maybe,
if you want to be in
and know everything,
you'll need augmented reality
wherever you like it or not.
So, Dotan, I would love to spend
the last five minutes or so,
talking about where we're headed.
Because I am terribly excited
and frightened of how our world
is going to look in a few dozen years,
both in terms of people
that are aging and loneliness
especially with covid.
I mean, it's become very apparent
how necessary this technology is.
But before that,
I would still have
to understand a little bit better
what is essentially
augmented reality today?
So, are people really
actively working on this?
Is this mainstream?
And I'm drawing a parallel
to autonomous vehicles.
I had a great chat
with a product manager
at one of the leading
autonomous vehicles company
on this show.
And one of the things
that she mentioned was that,
we had a big surge of technology,
we've advanced a lot.
And we've reached this like,
95-96% threshold.
And now we're realizing
that the last 5%
is incredibly harder than we thought.
And so we're almost there,
but we have such
a big way to go because
that's the big threshold.
Is that the same thing
with augmented reality?
I think yes and no.
I think it is yes because
if you want something perfect,
there's still a lot of things
to do to make it work.
I think there's a problem
with augmented reality
is the awkwardness.
There's no stable killer applications.
Why would people like Google,
when they have the Google glasses.
Yes, you get more information,
but you look awkward.
If there's not enough extra information,
still people are waiting
for this killer application
that is not there yet,
maybe just games,
but it's not enough,
just games and entertainment.
The technology is really,
it's getting there.
It's not too far for something
that you can use but expensive.
So the glasses,
like HoloLens, Magic Leap,
that's something that costs
2 or $3,000 a piece.
That's too much for consumers.
So, that's something
that has to be solved
before people can use it.
Because with expensive ones,
you have very good results.
Very, very good.
But if you want something
that is much cheaper,
10 times cheaper,
then checking is not good enough.
But that's the hardware.
I mean hardware
is getting better, cheaper.
The camera is getting cheaper.
I think technology, of course,
there's more to do improve,
but I think we're in the right way.
And I get the killer application,
why would people do it.
In the future,
they talking about also lenses
instead of glasses.
You don't see it
but the hardware it's very creepy.
I don't know.
But I think, I believe that
that's something again,
like, even if you like it or not,
It's going to happen.
It's going to happen. Yeah.
Because I'm asking this
very honestly,
because we had such a big hype.
And everybody was talking about it.
We had Magic Leap
that was in stealth mode for so long,
raising so much money.
and then all of a sudden,
you stop really hearing
about these advancements.
You do have Oculus and HoloLens,
but you don't really see
me and my friends
talking about these technologies
as much as we did
even five years ago.
Which is counterintuitive.
Because I would expect
that now, we'd be talking about it
much more than before.
I remember going to conferences
and the person with the Google Glass
was the most popular person in the room.
So, what I'm hearing from you is that
I can be optimistic
and I should be planning
for a nearby future
when it will be less awkward
and more beneficial
to take part in this new humanity.
Yes, I think that's the directions.
And because, again,
there is so much things
we can learn and do with that
and so much extra information
you can get.
So, I think, sooner or later,
maybe later,
but it's going to happen.
And again, there's also the prices
that are going to drop.
I think so many big players out there.
And like you said,
it was very big hype
and some small companies were closed
because it's difficult to get some air.
Right.
But the big companies are still there.
And I think it's going to happen.
Maybe not as soon as they thought
but it's going to happen.
So, now is the part
that I'm most excited about.
Where are we heading?
Let's say, 10 years down the line
or 20 years down the line,
what do you envision
our world will look like
with augmented reality
as part of our society?
In a modest expectation.
Given the technology
that you're expecting to grow,
how do you envision humanity operating
or at least places like Tel Aviv,
Silicon Valley, New York?
Okay. So, maybe we have
to separate which one what I want
and maybe what I think
that's going to happen because
it's not that I like,
Yes, I like the technology.
First of all, augmented reality,
like I said before,
from the technology side,
as a developer, from contribution
production, integration.
Yeah, but I'm not sure
that there's a use of it I really like.
If I just try to imagine
all this creepy situations,
I'm not sure I really like
to have it in the future.
It's also scary for me.
But if we just mentioned
this corona thing,
we sometimes go far from the family
being able to,
so that's the good thing.
So, that's the thing that I really think
that are beneficial.
Now, everything is virtual.
We are in Zoom right now,
but I want to make a meeting with you
and we want to discuss something
that here is on the table,
and with AR glasses,
we can discuss it.
It's already possible with some
with more advanced headsets
that are too expensive,
like I mentioned earlier.
But now you can already look
at the same object
and look at that around it.
So, I think for high tech,
for many other for professional use,
there are a lot of things
that you can share
and be able to gain a lot of,
and safe like Zoom.
You don't have to meet to do it.
You can do it from home.
And like you also mentioned,
for the elderly people
maybe they can not read
because it's too small.
But now you can,
assuming that you do that in the UI
simple enough and intuitive enough,
that's also a challenge.
Because, we know, If it was computer,
we use the mouse and the keyboard,
we are already used to it.
But with augmented reality,
how to use.
So, there are a lot of challenges there,
the uiPAD.
The technology have hand checking
and head checking, the eyes checking.
None of that was very useful.
It worked, but not so.
If you want to change,
do something like that,
to change the screen
or do something like that.
Hand signs that are not very intuitive.
If we solve that,
I just mentioned that
because we think about old people.
So, if you make it intuitive enough
and maybe hopefully will find a way
to interact with that.
So, family that want to meet each others
and together with the holograms
or things like that,
you could really feel like,
so, every time it use augmented reality,
even more virtual reality.
Sometimes I use it
and then, I when I'm done,
I just take my glasses off and
oh, wow, I'm back to the real life.
I'm back to the boring world.
Yeah.
It is so easy to forget
about your environment
when especially with virtual reality.
And that's something that I think
that if we find again,
like some applications
that something that can
do a lot of good to people.
I'm terribly excited about
the prospect of being able
to talk with my grandparents from afar.
Due to covid,
I can't go inside their house
and visit them.
And it kills me inside.
And I'm saying like,
why do I need to use video conferencing
on Shabbat dinner
to wish them Shabbat Shalom.
I want to be able to be
in the same room with them
because it feels to me
that were almost there.
And it's so relevant today
and it's going to continue
being so relevant moving forward.
And so, I'm incredibly excited
about this technology.
And one more thing,
there's a haptic feedback.
That's something that is still missing
and that's more expensive.
That's part that is a bit behind,
because you also want to touch.
You want to hug your grandparents,
If you could hug them or something,
And there are some
controllers that just vibrate a bit,
but it's not much more than that
and the better ones are very expensive.
Right.
That's something that has to,
maybe in 10 to 20 years,
I hope that this one
will get much, much better
because that will make
a lot of difference.
Right. I just read an interesting review
of the new PlayStation game console,
which the PlayStation 5,
it introduces haptic feedback
through the remote controllers
so that you're more immersed
into the game.
And one of the things that they said
and I read a few of the gamers designer's
decision making process,
they said that they intentionally
minimized the use of this new feature
because they were afraid that humans
will not be receptive to it yet.
It will be too much for them.
So, I'm especially curious,
given what we talk here
about how we as humanity
are going to accept this new reality.
And just like you mentioned,
that you take off those glasses
and you're back into the boring world,
or the default world, whatever.
Every person experience it differently.
I think that's fascinating.
Dotan, I want to really thank you
for being so generous with your time.
I wanted to talk about J-Ventures
and some of the work that we do there,
but we didn't have time for that.
But I'd love to get from you three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
So, one is very active.
So, I always prefer to do something
than not to doing something,
So, even when I wake up in the morning,
I want to go jogging or not,
and I am tired,
I'm not going to Jjog today.
But I remember that,
whenever I'm doing something
or when I do something
I never regret.
I love that.
Even if you regret
I know I'll regret more times
about things I didn't do
than about something
that I want to do.
So, whenever I have to think about
should I do it or not,
my approach is yes, do it.
Like a startup, just do it.
I love it.
That's one thing.
And the other thing is just,
I think I'm very calm.
So, it's very difficult for me
to someone to make me angry or mad.
It's very difficult to make me mad.
Maybe that's why I don't have
so much startups,
because I'm calm.
You seem very fulfilled and calm.
And I'm taking a lot of inspiration
from that first word,
being active and not regretting
even when your intuition says
maybe this isn't right,
but then you rationalize and you say,
well, I'm more often than not,
I don't regret,
I'm enjoying the experience.
And so, I think that's really wonderful.
Wonderful.
Dotan, thank you very, very much.
Thank you for being on the show.
Thank you for
being so generous with your time.
And I'll see you around
at J-Ventures meetings.
Yeah. See you.
Bye-bye. Nice to talk to you.